[Musique]
non je peux pas mettre ça je vais être
démonétisé encore le deuil c'est vrai
dit il est passé - 18 parce qu'un mec
qui souffle sur sa main vont mettre une
petite claque à quelqu'un en bas c'est
pas fameux livre m lisa messieurs dames
comment allez vous comment sonne los
hijos d'elle comme honey d'adp de mots
de plus par rapport à la même un trou en
espagnol de ya deux ans les anciens pour
les progrès aujourd'hui nouveau celui
d'aujourd'hui il est vraiment pas mal
j'ai mis du temps à cerner le concept du
samedi puisque c'est un délire anglais
qu'on n'a pas trop dans la langue
française le nom est le suivant to his
own
c'est comme s'il ya un truc à deux
points de vie mais tu pense qu'il en a
qu'un hb gaye déjà dans l'exp qui dort
il se passe un truc tu dis en bas c'est
la fin est en fait tu baves non il y
avait un deuxième point de vie cachée là
maintenant je vous donne l'explication
français quelque chose en cache un autre
un peu moins séduisant la version
française comme tout pour comprendre
mais la prière vidéo comme d'hab ça m'a
dit fois plus vite regardez c'est
quelqu'un qui fait un bowling il reste
une quille mais en fait derrière c'est
qu'ils cherchaient alors c'est pas à
chaque fois un truc cacher derrière
notre que vous avez compris cette
mécanique que je trouve vraiment
marrante et qui était très à la mode il
fut un temps vous savez avec les mecs
qui j'en faisais j'en ai retiré le
masque en fait sous le masque se cacher
le même masque doit le secret derrière
les bouteilles qui respecte
l'environnement c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup d'efforts autour du packaging
pour réduire le plastique ça fait
plaisir à voir
salut je suis une bouteille en carton
tu as droit de faire ça genre tu te fais
pas attaqué par 18 associations en même
temps c'est une véritable honte c'est
keith et jayden smith dans ce cas lancer
une marque d'eau dans des bouteilles en
carton bon malheureusement ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher que les bouteilles en
plastique mais c'est un bon début
le schip shipping shipping shipping
chips
si vous avez qui fait c'est que vous
êtes bilingue moi j'ai mangé un mal de
tête
actuellement c'est un bateau de
livraison qui livrent des bateaux de
livraison elle a fallu du temps pour
rire on en est là ce petit monument à
une mascotte de lui même aux non à ces
adorables cp du adorable s'éclipser plus
que deux c'est un truc de perruques là
attendez attendez attendez vous avez vu
la densité de cheveux la casse sur le
crâne
j'ai l'impression que il ya un peu de
cheveux à l'e3 là dedans excusez moi non
attends ça se trouve je dis un truc
[Applaudissements]
elle est très chaude bravo ça me manque
les fêtes au village je mange j'en ai
jamais fait ça m'angoisse alors ça alors
ça c'est incroyable
une bougie conçu de manière à ce que
quand il ya du vent etc est une flamme
qui s'éteint les autres l'art allume
automatiquement c'est ce qu'il faudrait
pour les couples ça gène ikke l ambiance
qu en a deux qui s'éteignent ça marche
aussi il ya des objets comme ça il ya
tellement du minck ont toujours rêvé que
ça existe et qui pensaient que ça
n'existait pas que quand un mec découvre
que ça existe il en fait du dropt
shipping et tout est là d un poids qui a
eu ça c'était sais pas si vous vous
souvenez quand il ya eu une méga chaleur
en 2020 il y avait un petit climatiseurs
fait pour chez toi dans lequel tu
mettais de lola tout le monde l'a
achetée le jour où des moustiques nous
envahissent vous allez voir les bougies
à la citronnelle tri flammes
il va y en avoir partout dans les pubs
un style tout partout la naissance d'une
barre de vie il sole avec leurs délires
de bar de village je comprends qu'à
moitié
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça oya la petite
poubelle ils fatiguent tellement
d'énergie dans ce gag ce doit être une
pub dont j'avoue j'ai pas vu trop de pub
pour des pelleteuses mais je pense à un
tiroir dans un tiroir pour cacher quoi
bah oui ceci dit j'aime beaucoup le fait
de devoir juste tourner les boutons du
truc dans un autre sens c'est un peu
style et comment elles sous ce deuxième
tiroir après c'est très glauque je suis
pas américain
je trouve ça glauque kaiser qui sifflent
chien mais attends mais c'est vraiment
le chat de la boîte c'est incroyable
ah ils avaient tout préparé il avait
découpé au le force heures il a près dé
couper la tête du chien de l'emballage
il a enfermé son chat dedans et il
tapait à la porte pour que le chat sorte
par la têt du chat de l'emballage france
ô j'ai adoré je rigole j'ai adoré ça
m'affecte trop pas t'imaginer doigts
s'ils ont une année je faisais 265 story
de natsu de chiba et nous tellement je
suis gaga quoi le truc de fou les gardes
vous souvenez de cette légende quand on
était petit il ya ça dans plusieurs bd
moi j'avais vu dans kid paddle est un
film au cinéma qui est interdit aux
moins de 18 ans comment tu fais pour
aller le voir alors que ta 13 ans et
dans les bd souvent et présenté sa part
tu prends ton pote sur tes épaules vous
mettez les habits de papa vous fermez
bien le manteau du coup on dirait que
c'est qu'une seule et même personne et
même si cet humain a une tête d'enfant
de 13 ans ça passe là où ils ont fait un
remake de ça ils sont dit comment faire
pour aller au cinéma mais payer qu'une
seule place au lieu de deux c'est
beaucoup d'énergie les gars pour
économiser les places de cinéma mais
regardez il se met contre son pote il
leur couvent de son tee shirt trois fois
trop grand pour lui il habite du double
xl s'est cramé à 3000% il va au guichet
du ciné il demande une place pour le
film le gars pas de soucis tenez votre
place et une fois arrivés vers la salle
de cinéma au plat la supercherie est
finie on a économisé 5 euros
étant un très petit gabarit commenté pas
assez bon tranquille j'ai grave envie
d'essayer
juste pour le kiff d'avoir essayé même
si ça me coûtait plus cher au final
parce que je dois acheter des vêtements
grand suis-je une très mauvaise
influence
oui quand tu n'as pas réussi à décider
entre à une fatigue entre un jean et un
pantalon kaki
je n'ai jamais vu ça à part les
spectacles là où ils s'arrachent les
fringues
il y en a d'autres en dessous qui ce qui
peut amener à mettre un jeans ou un
short truc s'il est haché et qu'il n'a
pas pu laver maintenant c'est un pas de
sens si tu mets ce truc-là direct mais
ce truc là la trop grande qui plus est
[ __ ] mais la tenue de ce mec c'est une
escale game je dois essayer de sortir
j'y arriverai pas c'est tellement lourd
à chaque fois qu'il boit de l'eau y
passe un mauvais moment parce qu'il sait
que ça fait rire les gens autour de lui
sa vie n'est qu'une malédiction rempli
de moqueries et d'angoissé à l'idée de
s'hydrater s'hydrater étant primordiale
pour survivre et être en bonne santé
je vais lui offrir un seul et vidéo
comme ça qui est trop drôle de l'ina ou
ses missions dans les années 80 et vont
voir des gens qui ont subi des moqueries
à cause de vents de familles et de leurs
familles et mec c'est horrible mais il
ya un truc humains dans ton cerveau
primitif où tu rigoles nichons c'est dur
à porter non pas du tout c'est injuste
moi c'est au charbon de famille donc
quand j'étais plus jeune on disait un
clochard et c'était pas drôle et mon
père à son époque c'était une autre
blague c'était aux chars d'assaut on
sent que la guerre était pas loin des
blagues c'était pas trop les mêmes
people of all bat ce mec là regardez
comme dans cette chemise il est
resplendissant évidemment qu'il en prend
deux autres comme ça quand celle là est
au sol en attendant d'être lavés ils
enchaînent directement avec une hotte
donc petit prétentieux de snap shatter
ingrat que tu étais points
d'interrogation sont légitimes je
comprends je comprends tu te demandes je
comprends il ya des gens quand ils
aiment bien un vêtement genre quand il
trouve enfin un jean qui leur va bien et
qui trouve beau il l'achète en deux ou
trois exemplaires je vous jure c'est
hyper fréquents trouvez vous ça anormal
ou ok normal il ya un vrai débat bon ok
c'est la couverture d'un livre d'école
qui est constituée de jeunes qui
tiennent ce même livre d'école sur
lequel ils sont déjà sur la couverture
mexes as me mec ça m'embête comment
c'est possible et ce qu'ils ont
photoshop mais quels intérêts tarde
photoshopée pour que ce soit genre oh
c'est l'oeuf et la poule en version nul
c'est relou encore un pantalon sous un
pantalon
mais quelle est cette mode c'est relou
d'un ça doit pas être confortable non
plus mais [ __ ] j'suis ya une raison
pour le moment on ignore mais on va
évoluer on comprendra le style est ainsi
qu il a habillé sa canne le [ __ ]
c'est tellement une bonne idée quand il
m'est venu mais la même tenue à sa canne
c'est génial premier degré une figurine
d'un mec qui se tire lui même en
figurines un peu simple un peu on va se
mettre à juger premier degré parce que
là j'ai l'impression que plus on avance
plus attendre des choses bancal gars
pourquoi vous présentez cela s'est
clairement pas un mario dans un an c'est
juste à moustache dans un mario et comme
c'est le seul signe distinctif
oh ça me tue obama lé deal with it à
gaza
[Musique]
traille sont chiants ils font des
montages de ouf assez incroyable encore
ouais pourquoi j'adore cette mécanique
elle est hyper satisfait ça me fait
penser aux clips des casseurs flotteurs
à l'époque des histoires à raconter il y
avait ce truc un peu de lupu ça retire
mais en fait ça retire pas c'était un
peu ce en fait j'ai trois ans de retard
voilà disons cette mini rolex il ya eu
une époque comme ça où les bagues qui
indiquaient leur c'était un peu à la
mode pas trop ça jamais été trop à la
mode là effectivement il a peut-être
poussé un peu trop loin le le truc mais
bon il se fait dès qu'il faut
takashi murakami très célèbre artiste
japonais les fameuses fleurs vous avez
dû passer voir sur plein de fois c'est
lui et les assez fasciné par ce truc là
de fausses cher et tout fait qu'un peu
creepy je suis sur un style à elle est
bâtie sur un délire zombies lui version
zombie dernièrement qui est vraiment
bien fait tu kiffes non non non non j'en
ai marre expliquez moi je comprends pas
des pantalons sur des pantalons c'est
incroyable et encore là il ya un intérêt
ça me donne les faits vous savez c'est
comme les t-shirts comme ça que tu
achètes et là il ya une manche longue
qui sort de l'aïe qui va là encore là il
ya un intérêt de style mais l'autre
thaler n'y avait pas d'intérêt c'était
vraiment genre gratos au chaud gucci ya
un mannequin qui se baladait avec sa
propre tête dans les mains assez bien
creepy observe des monos toulouse est
allé chez le dentiste c'est une langue
de dante issa je comprends rien mais qu
aux salaires incroyable et chaouchi et
cowboys sont chiants les mecs ont
tellement bloquée sur ces mario dans
mario ils sont allés lui demander une
photo quoi la détermination ces jeunes
gens ils sont allés la chercher ses
nuits sont allés sur le terrain au
charbon pour nous la ramener fraîchement
sur reddit bravo les gars je suppose que
ce que vous avez dans les mares vous a
beaucoup aidés à ne pas trop ressentir
la gêne sociale que fut cette demande
oui oui messieurs dames cette vidéo
touche à sa fin ça m'a donné chaud bon
blague à part j'ai passé un très bon
moment je suis content d'arriver c'est
vrai dit c'était des trucs bien drôle
cette mégane et qu'elle écoule à petite
dose s'il ya que ça tout le temps
pendant longtemps ça devient très chiant
parce qu'on n'est plus surpris mais là
franchement ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas vu une telle quantité de
contenu qui usent de cette mécanique
j'espère que ça vous a plu je vous dis à
bientôt portez vous bien
et petit
[Musique]